today's episode is one of my favorites
we will be examining and debunking the
most ill-founded cultural historical
myths that you'll hear from the pro-gun
control crowd regarding the legal
political aspects of gun ownership and
all of their lives they're in
it's gun week continued its Fourth of
July week and Firearms are as American
as apple pie which I don't really know
how American that they had apples back
in the old country I think so we didn't
invent apples I don't know we put it
into a pie but this is a Mr guns and
gear you can go check out his YouTube
channel Mr guns and gear it's incredibly
helpful uh a lot of good information
there but we wanted to take this
opportunity we've done handguns 101 long
guns 101 the most common firearm myths
that you've probably heard and we'll
separate into two parts kind of cultural
political and then technical since you
know that's more in your realm sure
expertise
um and you've worked in the Firearms
industry too for a while yeah I've been
doing this for since 2014. yeah and the
funny thing is you know we can separate
the technical from sort of the because
sometimes people who work in the
Firearms industry they're not always
fully aware of the second amendment in
the historical context yeah that's very
common actually yeah it kind of
surprises more than it should be yeah it
shouldn't be but
um oh look we'll lead this uh with a
clip for you but right off the bat we'll
go through seven and maybe plus one top
Firearms miss that you've probably heard
culturally politically historically as
well as the rebuttals to those will make
all the references publicly available
but it's no secret that half of this
country at this moment in time is
vehemently against the idea of owning
Firearms there is a way for us to
make sure that lawful responsible gun
owners like yourself are able to use it
for sporting hunting protecting yourself
but the only way we're going to do that
is if
we don't have a situation in which
anything that is proposed is viewed as
some tyrannical
destruction of the Second Amendment do
you think that reinstating the ban on
assault weapons and banning
high-capacity magazines would do any
good yes
um I do we cannot let a minority of
people and it's that's what it is it is
a minority of people
hold a Viewpoint that terrorizes the
majority of people hell yes we're going
to take your AR-15 your AK-47 we're not
going to allow it to be used against
fellow American
if you want to protect yourself get a
double barrel shotgun I said Jill if
there's ever a problem just walk out on
the balcony here or walk out put that
double barrel shotgun and fire two
blasts outside the house I promise you
who's ever coming in is not gonna you
don't need an AR-15 it's harder to aim
it's harder to use and in fact you don't
need 30 rounds to protect yourself buy a
shotgun
so it's not one of the myths here but Mr
gunzinger and I were just laughing Mike
I'll call Mike in case you guys get
confused at uh former Vice President Joe
Biden saying that's way it's too hard to
control AR-15 use a double-barreled
shotgun yeah that's definitely much
harder to control it's incredibly
difficult to control AR-15 is hard to
aim is it with a red dot I mean it it
really couldn't be easier unless you're
Elmer Fudd so this brings us to uh seven
Miss so I think these are the ones that
you'll most commonly encounter um number
seven very common myth that you'll hear
that the Second Amendment how often do
we hear this only applies to muskets
uh what's the truth well there's still a
graphic there but look you're you know
this better than than probably I do but
historically the founding fathers were
well aware of of the technological
advancements with Firearms
um and there were actually at that point
in time many firearms that were far more
advanced than the the muskets that were
used in the military and it just wasn't
cost effective right uh or it was slower
to reload or there's different reasons
they went with it but yeah um there was
semi-automatic air guns were very common
in the period and when you think of an
Aragon a lot of people think of like a
pellet gun but these things were
legitimately lethal guns that could be
used for hunting self-defense or
whatever the case may be right
additionally there was volley guns which
had the capability to fire multiple
projectiles I mean there was a ton of
them yeah well so to give you an example
a few of them and you can check all the
references there was the callth off
repeater actually which is one I wasn't
super familiar with in a previous video
I addressed sort of the puckle gun the
pepperbox revolver there's the uh the
Belton flip lock there's the flintlock
machine gun actually and the girendoni
air rifle which you may not know that
was an air gun that was used the Lewis
and Clark Expeditions as a matter of
fact they use that high capacity air
rifle to Showcase to all the Native
Americans to say hey look how much more
powerful our boom boom sticks are to bow
and arrows it was something the
government was aware of and actually
encouraged to be used as a display piece
right so that's and not to mention of
course you would have to apply uh the
same rationale too well the first
amendment does not apply to the printing
press let alone to your iPhone to the
internet right and they were aware of
all these technological advancements
these guns existed back then they were
high capacity and let me give you one
more truth that I think is is pretty
important interesting it also applied to
canons
so this is actually a private letter of
of Mark in 1812 from James Madison to a
privately owned ship to have cannons
they basically were saying let me just
sort of summarize this for you they were
saying hey we're coming into contact
with you know like British forces and
we're out here on our ship we just want
to make sure is it okay for us to have
cannons and Madison said Second
Amendment yeah you can have cannons
which would be the equivalent to
approximately maybe uh like a javelin
like yeah something today an 84 yeah
some kind of Bunker busting weapon yeah
it was a very heavy art and by the way
you can also still have cannons you can
tell them shipped to your house today as
of right now you can have a huge cannons
shipped to your house and it's perfectly
legal there's no background check
nothing
okay well that's a conversation I don't
necessarily know that that's the I mean
I guess what are you gonna use a cannon
for right
YouTube videos yeah exactly if you have
someone small enough to fire it I mean
if you're working in the circus but the
point is canons back then the letter we
have I have commissioned the private
armed Brig called Prince new channel I
think I'm pronounced that correctly uh
mounting 18 Carriage guns
so this was something that again one of
the founding fathers knew about said
yeah you can have cannons uh which
brings us to another one uh myth number
six that you probably run into and this
is remedial for a lot of you but um for
a lot of folks it isn't you know they
still encounter these for example if
you're in high school you'll still hear
these myths right on a consistent basis
that uh the Second Amendment is only for
the militia you know what part what part
of your ass is part of a well-trained
militia we've heard that famous quote
right
um well let's I think first we can read
the Second Amendment sure thing to start
with that uh and and then sort of get
into more historical context the
corroborating documents that clarify
what constituted the militia so here is
the Second Amendment for people who
haven't actually read it
a well-regulated militia comma being
necessary to the security of a free
state comma the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed this is written pretty damn
carefully too it was uh I I don't think
they thought it would ever be challenged
like it has been because it's so clear
right
um like a regulated militia regulated
means well run right it doesn't mean
regulated by the government right it
means capable correct and here's another
Truth uh just because there are plenty
of corroborating documents right if it's
not just in the Constitution let's say
the the Constitution right in the the
Bill of Rights is the prescription well
then there's there are other
corroborating documents that sort of add
that like okay hold on a second this is
just a prescription that's been written
but this is how you would take it or
this is what is most effective or this
is the tape ring pattern there's a there
are a lot of of documents out there and
also conversations that were uh that
were notarized that would have been
written down that would corroborate this
and none to the opposite effect so this
is actually George Mason one of the
founding fathers for those of you who
don't know uh one asked well what is the
militia
he said I asked sir what is the militia
it is the whole people to disarm the
people is the best and most effectual
way to enslave them so the right
of uh the people comma that's after a
well-regulated militia comma being
necessary to the security of a free
state comma the right of the people and
to keep and bear arms and George Mason
said well what is a militia of course
it's the whole people you are the
militia any able-bodied particularly
able-bodied male who can carry a firearm
is part of the militia and you have the
right to keep and bear arms just don't
tell the FBI right yes exactly
I'm pretty sure everyone here is on a
list but we do so you don't have to
correct uh this one is right in your
wheelhouse uh myth number five
sure this one is is silly but you do
hear this a lot that a uh a pistol brace
makes a gun deadlier and we didn't know
if we should put this in the next
installment on technical myths but it's
sort of pervasive culturally right now
because of the laws that people are
facing so a pistol brace makes a gun
deadlier you can buy the brace
without a background check
but when it becomes a dangerous weapon
when that race changes the gun's legal
status
and makes it
in essence the same
that caused the mass shooting at a
Boulder Colorado supermarket
the stabilize Embrace made in a shorter
Barrel made a pistol
under federal gun regulations
it made it harder for people to buy
stabilized braces put a pistol on a
brace it turns into a gun
make some more you can have a higher
caliber weapon a higher caliber bullet
coming out of that gun so it's the truth
so it doesn't change
the deadliness if you will of it at all
if you look back at the history of the
National Firearms Act which is what
prohibited short barrel rifles and which
year was that 1934 1934 right um it
didn't prohibit them you just had to get
a tax stamp to have one but the reason
for that is they're trying to get rid of
like gangster guns if you will
um sawed-off shotguns things like that
things that were easily concealed so the
thing about it is if you take an AR
pistol and you remove the brace it's
actually smaller and easier to conceal
right than it is with the brace right
additionally brace pistols like for ARS
just for this example uh the reason
people are putting a brace on them is
because they have a barrel less than 16
inches well with AR-15s the amount of uh
I guess lethality damage that the round
is going to do is directly dependent on
barrel length right so
they're putting them on guns with
shorter barrels therefore they're less
lethal right it would be if you had a
full-size Rifle right and to be clear
the reason for that for people who may
not necessarily be super familiar with
Ballistics is um you have that powder
burning right and the longer the Builder
every round kind of has an ideal length
to sort of simplify it and a lot of that
powder is still burning which
accelerates the bullet right the round
has the powder and the bullet is just
the tip of it remember when you were
young you thought that whole thing was
the bullet right not the gun no it's the
tip basically at that little that neck
of the round that powder is still
burning and so unless with an AR is it
16 inches is what's optimal uh no so
somewhere between 20 to 22 is about
optimal depending on the round and it's
still pretty rare that you run into
people with like 22 inch yeah almost
never almost never almost never but
you're losing a lot of that velocity in
a shorter AR-15 that would be using a
pistol brace correct and that's when
we've done the ballistics video which
you can go and watch uh when people talk
about that sort of wound channel from
the air 15 that directly relates to the
speed right when you reach certain speed
that's where you get create that Hydra
static shock that sort of temporary
wound cavity which you wouldn't
necessarily be running into sometimes in
some scenarios with something that would
have that short of a barrel but really a
pistol brace was originally created for
people who were compromised to be able
to control the gun correctly uh Alex
Bosco is the man who created it the
owner of SP tactical and he created it
when he was with his friend who was a
marine veteran who couldn't use his
AR-15 properly because he was injured
and they were actually kicked off the
range because the range officer said
they weren't being safe so he created
the brace as a way to increase the
safety of the gun literally so why is
this such a big issue right now before
we go into myth number four why has it
become an issue now with this and we got
to get rid of you know the laws that
we're looking at pistol braces sure so
the reason is it's because they become
so popular and so pervasive so the
estimates are that there's anywhere
between 10 to 40 million of them out
there and
they've only been around since 2012 so
if you think about that many firearms in
that period I mean that's a sizable
number of guns that have been sold since
2012 and they're very popular because it
just helps a lot of things for example I
took a a new shooter out to the range
the other day a female who hadn't
shotguns before and I gave her a 16 inch
ar9 and she said oh it would be so much
nicer if it wasn't so heavy out front it
had a little bit of a shorter Barrel
well that's what the pistol brace
enables people to choose right right and
uh unfortunately they're trying to take
that away but it's also simply like I
said because they become so popular and
that's another thing we haven't
addressed this specifically but if you
even look at the assault weapons ban Act
Right a lot of these uh a lot of these
sort of I guess you say characteristics
of the firearms that make the meal are
entirely arbitrary for example if you
you know in in some cases it's if it if
the gun has any of these two
characteristics you know for example if
it's a butt stock and then if it has a
conspicuously protruding uh vertical
grip you know well honestly who defines
conspicuously that's the term that
defines it versus I guess
inconspicuously it's okay the pistol
grip on a pistol but on a rifle this is
okay this is now an assault weapon okay
assault weapon and I know you think I'm
being reductive that's actually true
that's absolutely true the ATF has
actually issued letters from their fat D
division uh which is their division that
I guess makes rules doesn't make rules
clarifies rules whatever they claim that
day um but they have issued letters
stating exactly what you just said in
writing for public consumption so yeah
he's not making that up which brings us
to a myth number four here this is one
we're just we just talked about the
assault weapons ban act that happened
under Clinton and you know obviously
just laps because even the left realized
this didn't really do anything
um it wasn't very effective and there
was backlash myth number four you'll
hear a lot is assault weapons need to be
banned because they're the preferred
weapons of mass murder now before we
even get into that and why it's not true
this is the problem with a myth that
starts off with a false premise and the
people perpetuating it uh know it
assault weapon doesn't really mean
anything just to be clear assault rifle
was a term that was used and you can
correct me from in the military that had
select fire meaning it could be uh
changed from semi-automatic to a fully
automatic what you might consider
machine gun that's an assault rifle
right assault weapon
just means weapons that may be scary
looking to someone who doesn't know
about guns correct there's been at least
two assault rifles like that that were
real things uh the sternger bear that
the German Zeus literally translates to
assault rifle and then Bushmaster made
one that they might marketed in the
probably late 80s early 90s that was
called the assault rifle as well right
so yeah outside of those there's no
assault rifles right and then the term
assault weapons is even more it just
means uh whatever we don't like okay
means it's black and scary looking yes
exactly uh pistol grip no rifle grip ah
fine vertical foregrip no if it's
slightly angled it's not an assault
weapon anymore magic so let's so that's
the premise just deconstruct that if
someone says assault weapon they're a
silly goose you can tell them so uh but
let's go with what we think they mean
when they say assault weapon they're
probably talking about something that's
like an AR-15 or an AK-47 variant a
semi-automatic variant right rifle
variant okay here's the truth
um in 2020 rifles themselves this would
include all rifles they were responsible
for 4 108 murders that's three percent
of all firearm murders and when they try
and set the AR-15 these These Are The
Guns of mass Shooters it's their weapon
of choice 77 of uh wow that's it still
surprising me 77 of mass Shooters used
handguns
yep I mean that's true across the board
a lot of the most famous ones Virginia
Tech for one nine millimeter and 22
pistols both right yeah and it's one of
those things where sometimes they'll
have something that could be considered
an assault weapon right but they'll
actually fire more from a pistol or for
example a pistol carbine I believe in
Nashville yeah which was crazy yeah uh
she used a Kel-Tec Sub 2000 to actually
do the shooting but she had a brace air
15 pistol that would have been
possibly worse for folks involved I
guess but she didn't choose to use it
thankfully right yeah use the Kel-Tec of
all things I know of all things gross
it's gross so uh this brings us to miss
sorry Caltech I'm sure you have some
good things
uh myth number three and this is one
we've addressed on the show I believe we
have a clip
um but again it's a lie and it's an
agreed upon Lie from half of the people
in power in this country they know that
it's not true and that myth is that guns
and you'll hear this on CNN you'll hear
it everywhere I want you to remember
this check the references I make
available it is not true guns are the
leading cause of death amongst children
and according to the CDC the number one
cause of death for children ages 1 to 19
in this country is gun related violence
data from the University of Michigan
also shows gun violence increased
dramatically from 2020 to 2021
okay here's the truth and then I'll
point out something really silly with
that clip that you just saw
um
the leading cause of death among
children's children ages 1 to 14
accidents just to be clear now where
else do you ever hear
children's ages 1-19 you cannot find me
a board game that says ages 1 through
19. find me a show that is made for
children ages 1 through 19. we usually
have one and up which may mean one to
four four and up right PG-13 nowhere
else do we include a demographic that 1
through 19 which by the way includes
legal adults and people who can be tried
as legal adults we don't do that
anywhere else in our legal we only do it
here so that we can cheat those numbers
we can lie about those numbers so the
number one cause of death to be clear 1
to 14 years old which is still a pretty
wide spectrum right
is accidents now the the study that
these gun control Advocates are actually
using it defines kids again up to 19
years old 85 percent of those children
killed by guns in 2019 were in that 15
to 19 year old range
now you change that where you change the
the number in the study to men and boys
the number gets even smaller when you
classify by uh
race ethnicity and criminal background
that number gets even smaller it is not
it is and here's the problem with this
you put people at risk at danger if what
if people have a pool right but they're
thinking well the number one killer is
guns it's not even close the pool the
bathtub your toaster is more dangerous
to your four-year-old child than the gun
in a safe in your closet it's not even
close especially the pool one I've had
people who want to come over my house
with their kids and they'll be like oh
people have said to them rather oh he
has guns in the house be careful with
your kids over there well I also have a
pool no one ever says that no one's ever
like he has a pool be careful bringing
your kids over there right I never get
that feedback which I would assume
because you don't have kids at your own
you probably don't have a fence around
it the pool yeah we have to I believe
it's law is it law I believe so okay
it's not law in every state right I
won't let my kids go to your place you
don't have a fence right yeah you can
imagine you can leave the guns thrown
about the floor
but the pool is by far more dangerous
pool bathtub trampoline it's one of
those things that it's it's a lie that's
repeated often enough you've heard that
old adage but I'd like for you to think
of it a different way it's an agreed
upon lie do you believe that former Vice
President Joe Biden doesn't have access
to these statistics do you believe that
Barack Obama doesn't know better Kamala
Harris Nancy Pelosi do you believe that
they actually think one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen-year-olds are
at greater risk
of being killed by a firearm then common
accidents than automobile accidents then
common household items of course they
don't
don't fall victim to an agreed upon lie
just because enough people agree on it
which brings us to uh this one's always
fun myth number two you hear this a lot
you do is that you're more if you have a
firearm in your house you're more likely
to have it used against you right here's
uh the truth
um no
[Laughter]
but they cite one study which we'll make
available and it's flawed in a multitude
of ways everybody in the study just to
be clear had already been shot
so that matters because you're starting
the sample pool with people who've
already been you're excluded from the
study if you haven't if you haven't been
shot correct and that matters because uh
some people estimate the vast majority
but at least on the lowest estimate half
of all defensive firearm uses don't
require a single shot fire right simply
the presence of a firearm it's
definitely higher than half yeah I'm
just trying to be generous to the doctor
so I saw some that's only half but what
would you estimate it as probably 90 or
higher yeah exactly easily yeah it's
just very strong deterrent just like how
many times uh you know do you hear about
a guard dog mauling somebody it's pretty
rare they know there's a guard dog they
move on correct that's why I would say
as much as I love Firearms get a dog
first if you're looking to keep your
house safe you should have security uh
security system and a dog is one of the
greatest deterrents um it's your eyes
and ears when you know if you're well if
you're blind deaf and dumb I mean I
don't know Helen Keller might need a
guard dog but the point is Firearms are
important but it's not the Panacea uh
but just just one note on this so this
is back in the 90s Oprah did a show on
this topic right saying it was more
dangerous to have guns in your house my
grandparents had World War II bringbacks
like historically significant guns my
grandfather got put in the hospital uh
with an infection and so my grandmother
when he was in the hospital sold all of
his World War II bring back guns and
didn't tell him and now we don't have
them well yes for real sold them off for
200. it's fooled by Oprah yes she was
fooled by Oprah oh my God but but
unfortunately now our family doesn't
have those firearms that are you know
historically significant because of this
stupid myth well the good lord giveth
and then take in your case he taketh
away but I told you about the three
World War II era firearms that I found
in the Attic in my house yes I found an
old Colt Woodsman and then uh uh
whatever I think it's a Beretta that's a
25 okay Oliver and then another uh Colt
that was uh from the 1930s now here's
the thing he was in a crawl space that
was newly built it's not like it was old
the construction workers this year 5
found three firearms that are between
the years 1934 and I think 1942.
um so maybe they were your grandfather's
type they might have been they might
have made their way he's like the Tooth
Fairy right with guns here's something
else by the way in this study and I
highly recommend you go and check it out
because the method it's so flawed
um
the the the the the sort of the criteria
they use is they use interviews with
police and medical examiners right so a
lot of this is reported on third
reported by Third parties
um and here's how the case participants
were defined also by the way it doesn't
take into account firearm training at
all so this is a study that includes
only people who've been shot
right away or you don't make the study
and then you're basically on commentary
from police officers from medical
examiners these people may have not had
any firearm training whatsoever and uh
here's a quote as far as how the case
participants were defined we coded
control participants as in possession if
they reported any guns in a holster they
were wearing okay
in a pocket or waistband okay in a
nearby vehicle
or in another place quickly available
and ready to fire at the time of their
matched cases shooting okay so I'll give
them waistband holster right vehicle if
the altercation took place in the
vehicle right it doesn't really matter
if you're in your living room
uh or other place that could be quickly
available and ready to fire and that's
not clearly defined this is one study
that is so immensely flawed anyone who
cites again it's an agreed upon lie
right
also here's something else to take into
account there could be some truth to it
for example I was saying well if if
you're going to say that you're more
likely to ever be involved with an
accidental discharge if you handle a gun
then if you never if you've never
touched a gun absolutely true that's
true just like you're more likely to
drown if you ever enter a pool now that
doesn't mean that somebody who is a
competitive swimmer is more likely to
drown than someone who's never swim
before in their life right the moment
that you use that pool in your level of
experience
plays a huge significance in the danger
Factor right the same is true with
somebody who's proficient with Firearms
right exciting Basics by the way it's
not that hard to make sure that you
don't do something unsafe with a firearm
it doesn't take that long and then of
course you train it up as best as you
can all right this brings us to myth
number one and it was hard to pick
number one and we'll do the technical
issues that's pretty fun because that's
really his realm of expertise sure I'm
just a I'm a caveman when it comes to
that I usually just throw my firearm
it's a technique yes I throw it and do
this when you shoot if I have a home
Intruder velocity the bullet is more
likely to hit them in the cylinder yes
than it is to actually be used as a
projectile uh but the number one myth
you hear this a lot is nobody needs a
high capacity magazine
there's no reason someone needs a weapon
of war with 100 rounds 100 bullets
that can be fired
from that weapon
nobody needs that
nobody needs that you just heard a
former Vice President Joe Biden that
clip early on and say you know you don't
no one needs that just get a shotgun
Fire Two Rounds again I don't know how
he can be all places at all times and
know that that's what you would need but
even going with that again most
defensive uses of firearms okay don't
involve the weapon being discharged at
all I want to be clear about that now
when you get to the point where you're
in a gunfight meaning there's an
exchange of gunfire or you have to use
your firearm that number changes
dramatically so the stats are skewed
with defensive uses of firearms zero
shots and then any shots and the numbers
significantly higher than you may
anticipate and to be clear this number
this number can be argued it's not
always necessarily clear because of the
way that people study gun violence isn't
always very accurate and it's often
politicized but the total average number
of shots that we see according to the
crime data that's available that would
be considered reputable to stop an
assailant is around 12. now let me
explain to you why that is the average
number of hits to incapacitate a shooter
is about 2.45 that's what they average
it out to the number of shots that
actually hit the assailant are one out
of five meaning four out of five tend to
miss that's something that a lot of
people don't take into account so if you
take five and you multiply it by 2.45
you end up with
12.25 shots on average now let's say
that that could be anywhere between
five and twelve let's say it's between 3
and 10. the point is the top end of that
with one assailant if you're missing one
out of five which is probably the most
clear statistic we have puts you well
beyond the idea of a double barrel
shotgun right and then you have three
guys that kick in your door yes and that
is something to the number of assailants
specifically involved in home invasions
um have gone up and uh this is one of
the you can look at the statistics or of
course you know what you've experienced
and you can believe your lying eyes and
ears this is exclusive video caught on
security cameras in the area where St
Louis County woman was shot and killed
from bullets started flying outside her
home as you can see someone turns around
in a yard and fire shots right at
someone and then that person returns
fire
Bob Marita Automotive Group Skyfox was
over the scene in the 300 block of
landshire Road in North St Louis County
with a tragedy Island voted around three
Tuesday Morning in the video it appears
multiple people were exchanging gunfire
from outside the victim's home on the
front yard we were told the woman was
inside the home terrifying moments
caught on camera as a phoenix homeowner
protects themselves from several
suspects trying to break in the Phoenix
Police Department released this
surveillance video tonight you can see
four men kicking in a front door only to
be met by gunfire from the homeowner
that homeowner says they were alerted by
a motion sensor linked to their
surveillance cameras and they were able
to arm themselves just seconds before
their door was kicked in the suspects
quickly fled the scene in a gray car
before officers arrived I think that guy
just said a new 40 time he did it was
quick very quickly quick out of the gate
one thing I wanted to add uh just
getting back to the incapacitate someone
yeah
um especially with handguns which is
what the majority of folks are using
they've done studies on
incapacitation if you will and uh
varies by the study just like everything
else we've talked about but somewhere
between 70 to 85 percent of people who
are incapacitated when they get shot
it's a psychological stop right so you
don't want to count on it right so in
order to physically incapacitate someone
uh with especially with a handgun you
have to hit their central nervous system
right that's the only way so other than
that uh it's either they bleed out or
they quit right so and that's something
you can't count on it right I'm gonna
touch on the technical myths uh in the
next installment which I would recommend
you click below or just you can go
through the the playlist where you'll
get some people saying this will say
well 20 more people are killed by 22s
well that that's true but if someone is
killed or it could be true right in
other words it can be just as lethal but
if you die four hours later in the
emergency room something you may not
like you can get a lot of raping done if
you're wearing your old lucky raping
slacks uh in those four hours time so
it's about that like you're saying that
Central Nervous System Shock and
capacity and Trauma and usually that's
either actual neurological damage occur
or immediate blood loss as opposed to
something lethal because you can get
pierced through a lung and still go on
for a while absolutely and aside from
rape
they can be holding a gun squeezing the
trigger exactly so that's probably more
important in that instance well I mean I
don't know I mean both tomato tomato
they both seem unpleasant they do I
agree with that I'd rather be shot than
face old old rapey mcriberson's lucky
rape and slacks I mean I tell you what I
have heard stories and I don't want to
take part uh but that'll bring us
actually to the next installment the
technical myth so hopefully this has
helped in inform you Enlighten you uh if
you like it click the like button
subscribe comment below which myth you
run into the most and where you've heard
it because we've been through this this
is kind of remedial we've done these as
different videos in the past but we
wanted to compile them as a reference
piece and always make the references
available to you so that you can dive in
a little bit deeper and I highly
recommend looking into that study
regarding you know you being more likely
to have your firearm used against you
it's it's very eye-opened blood is an
understatement yes it's an understanding
and you think well there must be others
no there really aren't that's what will
often happen it will come from one piece
of cherry-picked information from a
flawed study that then becomes something
that is repeated everyone knows that's
true yeah everyone knows that's true
everyone knows that you're more likely
to have your firearm used against you
and then you just think well how awesome
how would that how would that happen do
you have any idea how hard it would be
to Steven Seagal your gun against you
it's slightly more difficult than in the
movies yes slightly especially well
especially if you're if you have your
lucky rape and slacks on you so uh we'll
see you in the next installment
technical Miss with Mr guns and gear
check out his YouTube channel uh this
man knows far more about Firearms well
he's forgotten more than we'll ever know
and uh see you in that next installment
gun week
thank you
[Music]
if you like this video click like
consider subscribing or comment below
and of course consider tuning in to the
live show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern right here on this channel